姐，
我31岁，
事业编，
长相可以，
父母体制内，
兄弟姊妹多，
最近相亲一个男生，
男生呢啊，
也是事业编，
34岁，
房子还有贷款，
车子10万左右，
不知道他是贷款的还是全款的，
经济条件是过得去的。
家里呢，
三个兄弟姊妹啊，
三兄弟加一个妹妹啊，
其他人都在大城市，
只有他在四线城市，
学历是大专。
父父亲是做生意的，
母亲是体制内的，
接触了几次，
人品性格还可以，
身高173，
衣品还可以，
最大的问题就是长相很一般，
看着不太顺眼，
五官比例不协调，
看起来没有那么舒服，
有点秃顶，
为了掩饰他的秃顶，
头发从后面梳到前面盖住，
导致发型很潦草，
整个人看起来有点滑稽。
我岁数也大了，
他经济条件又不错，
家里也跟我说可以了，
不要再挑剔了，
我现在也非常纠结，
很多天都睡不着觉。
我跟他出去过几次，
但是我生理上心理上都不太想跟他接触，
比如不想跟他牵手，
不想和他走太近，
也不想跟他待太久。
他的工资福利公积金什么的比我好啊，
他是市值的事业编，
我是乡镇的事业编，
我的学历是本科，
身高162，
我自己呢，
也相了无数次的亲啊，
总是因为这样那样导致了年龄大了，
我本身可能比较挑剔吧，
既要又要，
我也知道不能这样，
选中一样就可以了，
岁数也大了，
怕拒绝这个以后遇到的只会更差。
家里人也这样跟我说，
你们为啥都在笑啊，
人家这么苦恼这个姐妹这么苦恼的事情，
我们在直播间帮她分析，
你们为啥都在笑，
你们是不是在笑人家偷顶这个事儿，
笑人家头发潦草这个事儿，
我跟你说，
这都不是事。
秃顶可以直接给他剃光了，
戴帽子都行，
这都不是事儿，
你知道这个故事里面特别重要的是哪个点吗？
就龙飞姐能捕捉的是哪个点，
特别重要的一个点就是这女孩她不想跟人家亲近啊，
她生理上心理上她对人家排斥，
如果是这种情况的话啊，
嗯，
实话说啊，
你要是因为自己年龄大了，
因为对方其他条件好，
然后你也凑合凑合，
你跟他去结婚，
这件事儿是对人家不负责的。
大家能明白龙飞姐讲的这个逻辑吗？
就是你生理上心理上你都排斥他，
你不想跟他亲近，
都不想跟他拉手，
都不想跟他长期待着，
肯定是不能说，
因为我年龄到了，
我就将就吧，
我就跟他结婚吧，
你这样是对人家也不公平啊。
大家能明白吗？
有很多东西，
他就是讲人和人，
就是讲那个缘分，
但是你可能跟他没有那个亲近的感觉，
咱就是说找人结婚这事儿，
不一定是找那种，
你对他因为各方面都特满意对吧，
就看见人家就恨不得就缠人家，
就这那的，
不一定找这样的，
但一定是找一个你不讨厌她，
你不讨厌她亲近你的，
我这么少讲不过分吧，
我直播间的对吧，
结了婚的姐妹们是不是这个理儿，
一辈子很长的，
你要找一个你生理心里都抗拒的这么一个人的话，
你是对人家也不负责任的姐妹，
就抓紧时间再找，
抓紧时间再相亲。
是吧，
最起码你要找一个你不抗拒他的，
你不讨厌他的吧，
他拉你的时候你不讨厌是吧，
他提你的时候，
你不会生理性的，
对不对，
不会躲是不是。
就这意思。